et l'autre on voit un mac arrive alors
personne s'étonne quand mais c'est ça
qu'on aime dans cette émission a on aime
beaucoup d'abord le mec arrive vraiment
mais en fait vous en fait créé mais en
tout cas c'est des années d'expérience
il me fait très peur je pense qu'il va
rester comme ça jean luc lemoine on a
des questions pour nous et on rappelle
aux téléspectateurs pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent
jean luc lemoine s'intéresse à tout ce
qui se passe en off dans cette émission
exactement pendant les pubs dans les
coulisses ces partis première question
d'un tennisman en est exceptionnellement
avant d'écouter une question je voudrais
remercier tous les gens qui apprécient
cette rubrique et en particulier jean
michel maire même si c'est presque
gênant cet enthousiasme nous sommes en
direct qui va avoir une émission de
folie aujourd'hui je vous dis tout de
suite puisqu'on aura les questions en
4/3 de jean luc lemoine
botha le chanteur
et les fautes en
et enfin chaud au coeur j'étais là
l'événement effet je vais pas renier
dans les quatre tiers aujourd'hui
je lui ai dit oui il n'y a pas d'image
de taux exceptionnellement non ben j'ai
menti
on sait que vous avez 7 ckoi et des
quotas mais moi content allez question
tout de suite bonjour je m'appelle
dominique je suis très étonné mais il
paraît que dans une de vos émissions
jean michel maire aurait dit quelque
chose de gentil un de ses collègues
est-ce vrai ou juste un odieux mensonge
pour lui faire du tort
l'excellent chris lowe enchères dominik
meichtry ce que vous y avez vraiment
bien nantis en fait il a gobé les
parties se vanter en plus c'est sacré
à la fin je pense que tout ceci n'est
qu'un une infâme rumeurs pour nuire à
jean-michel alors j'ai cherché dans des
choses gentilles dans toutes mes
archives
j'ai un peu galéré mais j'ai fini par
trouver alors là il félicité bernard
montiel pour sa coiffure
généralement ça commence comme ça jean
luc est ce que je suis d'accord ce mal
extraits du siècle mais un pouce levé
sympathique s'était jamais arrivé et je
suis content de vous montrer surtout
quand c'est vraiment sincère
il ya plein de mecs lumbres ans et
jean-michel mais revoilà avec ses
qualités et surtout ses défauts et les
qualités on cherche encore ah oui là il
a du mal à être gentil oaci sinon il ya
le jour nous recevions le jeu est de la
france a un incroyable talent oui je
connais c'est l'italien oui bien sûr il
ya nos fait paris ni exactement
pelloni npp l'année pour moi oui ça me
fait pas rêver on peut l'appeler comme
on veut le faire son personnel est très
très basse par était content je
t'épargne bien aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué en fait le seul avec qui il
est vraiment sympa jean-michel tiens bah
ouais il est pas fou le pépère et c'est
qui le nourrit un alors là c'était lors
d'un happening avec nagui à l'ailé vu
jouer au tennis sur un court de tennis
aujourd'hui le monde est là
obama rattrapé c'est fini les joints
châtaignes d'athènes y avait beaucoup
parlé de vous maintenant comme ça oui
c'est ça le gard et le gaz se sont
regardés il fait des commentaires
maintenant ça y est il est comme ça je
vais très fort mais aussi je pensais que
c'était une teigne et finalement non pas
parce que si d'accord ils l'attaquent un
peu mais en fait loin des plateaux jean
michel est complètement différent et
c'est dans une interwiew sur le net que
j'ai redécouvert alors ça s'appelle il
était une voix et d'ailleurs dans cette
interview vous allez voir la journaliste
nathalie karsenti est une très jolie
voix
le problème c'est qu'elle qu'une jolie
voix donné le surnom de jean michel
mercier il ya un côté un peu surréaliste
aujourd'hui il était une voix reçoit
jean michel maire l'un des
incontournables trublions ne touche pas
à mon poste surnommé mister tab est à la
base un journaliste reporter au parcours
particulièrement brillant
avec une voix suave comme ça
particulièrement brillant mais il
s'appelle mr club alors je me dis tout
de suite
la journaliste était plus que sous le
charme c'est un euphémisme mais
franchement ça ne s'est pas vu
et ce qui est bien vous allez voir
exemple celle ci que quand une femme le
chauffe un peu son visage se transforme
et il fait une bouche en cul de poule
alors regardez ce sera ma peine là vous
avez cette image du séducteur qui se
prend des râteaux moi je ne comprends
pas trop parce que je vous trouve très
beau mais
on va revoir la scène prend bien soin
compte que a priori il a bandé patron
parce que je trouve très beau mais le
mieux c'est le bonheur on leur rappelle
que ces gens si c'est ça c'est du hockey
il est évident un peu ailleurs fait sa
bouche en cul de poule
bon à part ça dans cette interview on a
appris beaucoup de choses sur
jean-michel car il s'est livré mais
comme jamais sur lui mais aussi sur ses
camarades de touche pas à mon poste
écoutez vous ne marquez pas vous
mouillez vos convictions mais vous
n'êtes jamais méchant jean-michel banon
nathalie parce que j'ai jamais compris
pourquoi il fallait absolument être
méchant pour pour essayer de de réussir
mais voilà gilles verdez bonsoir
et
en tout cas dans les lyonnais qui sont
méchants l'émission j'allais vous dis
non c'est pas mon rôle que les gens
soient méchants les shampoings naturel
méchant qui sont extrêmement sympathique
par ailleurs parce qu'ils les jeunes
passait la mèche la méchanceté par
posture c'est méchant pour pour light
rail et pour l'être pour faire la petite
phrase qui va s'affiner
souvent de sa seigneurie g mais après
qu'il eut été les gens soient méchants
passé c'est leur problème
chacun a ses travers
aulas
mais ça ça je pourrais le revoir japon
et revoir dix fois c'est bon mais c'est
exceptionnel je sais qu'à la fin il ya
des gens qui sont méchants mais chacun
ses travers à la mecque caucus en tout
cas on appelait show jean michel n'est
jamais méchant mais dans l'équipe le son
en plus et une balance ray ça me paraît
quand même étrange bg tva fier là julien
courbet avait demandé à bertrand
chamerois à l époque la vitesse normale
oui eh ben il avait demandé d'imiter
françois hollande farid aloui l'émission
d'eric un boulet que j'adore on
apprendra par les voitures de ses
lunettes
vous remarquerez que doit même pour
gilles verdez notre imitateur semaine
voire qu'antoine le vrai ça va lui faire
plaisir en marquant dans le péché nous
regarde et nous regardent par contre en
tout cas c'est pas très gentil gide
heureusement bertron ne fait pas que des
imitations parfois ils dansent qu'ils
soient pas aussi bons dans les débats y
apprend que pour danser dans mes rêves
les origines
eh bien ce n'est pas le grand amour le
sympa en fait dans cette bande sait qui
est qui
d'après vous gilles verdez qui rident
sigean et cyril qui s'inquiètent du
bien-être de tous à la par exemple ils
avaient peur qui n'aura soit en retard à
son émission de radio
vingt quatre pour les grenat ce que
c'est vrai à chaque fois je leur dis
quand ils sortent à pour leur émission
de radio mais jean michel maire il a
jamais imaginons plus 1 n'ont jamais
jamais mais même pas les deux même pas
mais je pense qu'ils aiment personnes
sont toujours michel jean michel les
précédents problèmes psychologiques
cette chose je pense que ça affectait
aussi un autre jour ciré complimenté la
jolie valérie bénaïm texture benhaim
personnes landais et un jour
balou choqué la brède est choqué quelle
déception pour elle parce qu'elle aurait
tellement aimé voilà moraux qu'elle est
méchante
on va dire que c'était un dérapage mais
je te préviens thierry si tu recommences
je le montre ton dérapage
ah bah tiens d'ailleurs
y'en a trop vous ici c'est pour ça il a
32 ans
et ça le fait rire regardez la dernière
de thierry moreau dans touche pas voilà
non je vous salut l'artiste
finalement jean michel avait raison il
ya des gens méchants cette émission est
certes pardon d'avoir douté de toi jean
michel on devrait toujours faire
confiance à l'esprit supérieur un esprit
vif
regardez là c'est la suite de l'extrait
cyril va lâcher une phrase dont il a le
secret valérie benaïm puis deux et
l'agent michel va se dire [ __ ] il faut
que je relève le défi admirer sa
vivacité
la languette rentrer la marette on te
dit tu habites toi une phlébite au nom
maintenant et non non on te dit de
rentrer le truc c'est pas gentil tout je
tâche d'attirer bras soit c'est pas moi
ma tristesse qu'elle réparait devant
danseurs faire ça on sort tout ça et
c'est pour sortir touche attache à turin
c'est bon ça y est
non mais merci ça donne envie c'est
facile après pour attirer les invités
d'après vous qu'est ce qu'elle en pense
marion gamin c'est pas discret
commission on adore la seule qui ne dit
jamais de mal de ses collègues bat
isabelle et pour une raison très simple
c'est parce que personne ne les écoute
et vous le savez chaque semaine elle
essaie de communiquer avec des gens mais
comme elle se prend souvent des vents et
des chroniqueurs maintenant s adresse
aux invités là nous reste à lyon donc
gérard hernandez qui miracle va lui
répondre mais c'était sans compter sans
et nohra
non non
effectivement il est très réussie le
prime
en avant première il a complètement rasé
de près mais il en faut plus pour
décourager isabelle donc elle va essayer
de rentrer dans la conversation de force
avec l'amicale soutien de christophe
carrière
dans ton coin j'ai dit oui mais je ne
crois tu pas vraiment étonnant ballet
isabelle et tente sa chance avec cyril
le passage
excusez moi alors c'est vrai qu'il y
avait il ya vait duquel j alors quand
les invités vous plante quand vos
collègues vous êtes ne vous adresse plus
la parole quand votre patron vous passez
devant sans vous calculez qu'est ce qui
vous reste à faire
eh ben vous parler à ceux qui vous
seront toujours fidèle
les gens du public ça fait longtemps que
l'on sait à toute élégance et je
m'imaginais arrête c'est mes filles mes
filles
et après on s'étonne qu'ils préfèrent
parler tout seul en pic des chaînes
nationales sur la ville non non non
wade wade go wade des hommes de base ce
qui veut dire à question suivante pas
bonjour je m'appelle héliades il paraît
que pour le remercier de tout ce qu'il a
fait pour la france
on va bientôt donner le nom de cyril
hanouna à des écoles
est ce vrai c'est une très bonne
question et y ait assez ait été c'est
vrai que ça serait naturel que ça se
fasse mais pour l'instant ce n'est qu'un
projet il ya bien une impasse cyril
hanouna ou lilas et une bibliothèque bab
hanouna camp messin mais pour l'instant
pas l'école
et pourtant ce crime fait beaucoup pour
les divertissements inventant chaque
jour de nouveaux rendez-vous comme par
exemple le coming next vous savez
reprenant les trois meilleurs extraits
la veille c'est sympa ça ouais c'est
sympa de prime abord on pourrait penser
que c'est une orbite facile
inconsistant a juste faire des
lancements eh bien pas du tout rocard
syrie se donne à fond à chaque fois le
problème c'est que c'est hors antenne
coming next great une minute et en une
minute j'ai le temps de toucher plus
qu'une
ça va nous savons en revanche ouais tu
préfères que je tâche à tout
là
tu as des flageolets dans ta culotte et
à des flageolets tentacules bafoue nos
refoulements niort foolish happy new
year food gaillard yahia diana da da da
da da da da da da da da da vinha
foundiougne da da da da da da da da da
da se retrouver quelqu'un bible
sympa mais il adore regarder attiches
pas alors plus au regard des égards
débat faussé le massatois voilà assez
proche du baste franck dubosc voilà et
elle a bien bouché et chaque jour
c'était sympathique parce que chaque
jour nous les chroniqueurs nous avons
conscience a travaillé qu'un génie et
comme nous nous sentons très privilégié
régulièrement nous allons dans le dire
dans les médias
ah ça faisait longtemps qu'on n'avait
pas fait le point sur ces séquences où
se mêlent l'admiration et la peur de
perdre son emploi pour tout de suite
le nouveau balmanais j'adore monde
installé depuis près d'un an dans le
classement
valérie benaïm perdent deux places et se
retrouve 5e
des animateurs moi je vais les classés
en deux catégories à ceux qui sont
capables d'être debout pour animer
l'émission de télé puis à ceux qui ne
sont pas capables d'être debout
il me dit pas de gros mots par exemple
essayer de trouver syrie faisant un gros
mot
ne te cache pas t'as vu ta veste baba
est a vu ta chatte et puis les bateleurs
les des types qui te vante un frigo
alors qu'il fait déjà moins 15 et voilà
et il fait partie de cette école la
syrie
elle avait marqué les esprits avec sa
comparaison avec bébel elle vient de
refaire une interview pour consolider sa
place mais elle recule quand même d'aran
enora malagré savez on a longtemps pour
moi c'est le jean paul belmondo de la
télé on a souvent dit que c'était le
guignolo est en fait c'est le magnifique
sachez le
c'est un producteur trois ans des
nouveaux talents et qui nous aide aussi
à progresser
cyril c'est le service alors qu'il prend
moi qui me lâche pas je peux en pleurer
quoi
puis aussi a donné une interview au buzz
média
il n'a pas pu cacher son bonheur
bertrand chamerois et avec série l'on
sait jamais ce qui peut se passer
et puis il y avait une ambiance super
hawthorne et qui pour le groupe
c'est un ensemble de choses qui me fait
rester ici je me semble il avait
commencé la saison dernière mais cette
année il continue à confondre le q26
ride avec un timbre tellement eu de
lèche jean-michel baer va te regarder
mon temps et mon éveil
sceptique même temps il est simple et ça
devient très dur
j'accepte lui-même 2004 en quatre ans
quatre ans j'ai vachement demander
beaucoup d'acteurs mes petits chéris et
bien sûr ce soit en direct saluer bonnet
il a enfin dit ce qu'il avait sur le
coeur depuis trop longtemps
il rentre directement à la première
place jean luc lemoine
puis je pense que pour tous les
chroniqueurs vous savez ce que c'est
c'est
ses toiles
celui qu'on suit est exactement c'est
pas anodin de véritables du berger parce
que tous les bergers venus et aussi la
déesse de la beauté